the Queen biopic Bohemian Rhapsody is
loaded with moments songs and details
that many fans will doubtless love but
did you catch them all
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video and revealing five
crazy little details and Easter eggs she
might have missed in the movie
keep watching to the end to find out
which Queen Fang member had a secret
cameo in the film and subscribe and
leave a comment about the movie for a
chance to win some awesome Bohemian
Rhapsody merch you can spot the
inspiration behind the cover art for
Queens second album in the opening scene
of the movie when Freddy walks past an
iconic portrait of Marlena Dietrich from
her 1932 oscar-winning movie Shanghai
Express the renowned photographer Mick
Rock had been hired by Queen to come up
with a striking image for their second
album Queen - after Rock discovered a
picture of Dietrich with her arms
crossed a lip from above with the top
light he proposed the look for the
band's album cover they agreed and
Freddie even imitated deep tricks arms
crossed and fingers spread posed and a
shot of the band lit in a similar way
appears as the opening of their Bohemian
Rhapsody music video after freddie tells
paul prenta to organize a spectacular
party at his home the movie gives us a
glimpse at some of the singers legendary
events and when they designed the set
for the big party scene the filmmakers
deliberately included references to
Freddie's interests and Queens history
in fact there's a moment where Freddie
passes by two scantily clad women riding
a couple of stationary bikes
that's an Easter Egg to Queens bicycle
race single which was released as a
double a-side with fat bottomed girls
the music video for bicycle race is
famous for being filmed with many nude
models all racing around on bicycles at
Wimbledon Stadium Mike Myers makes a fun
cameo in the movie is fictional EMI
executive ray Foster who refuses to
release Bohemian Rhapsody because it's
too long and radio stations won't play
it among Foster's many complaints about
the song is a little inside joke he
tells queen that Bohemian Rhapsody will
never be the kind of song that teenagers
will crank up the volume in their car
and stop head-banging - which is funny
of course because that's exactly what
mike myers did back in 1992 in the movie
Wayne's World when he and his friends
played Bohemian Rhapsody in their car
and started head-banging along to
music fun fact for Wayne's world Mike
Myers actually had to fight the studio
to get Bohemian Rhapsody in the film as
the producers originally wanted guns and
roses instead as they were very popular
when the movie was being made after
Wayne's world was released though that
memorable moment brought Queen back into
the spotlight in the US and when
Bohemian Rhapsody was re-released the
song reached number 2 on the Billboard
Hot 100 the Live Aid performance is one
of the highlights of Bohemian Rhapsody
the where of course many famous bands on
stage that day and if you look very
carefully in the scene at the start of
the film as Freddy's going on stage just
coming off stage as a young bono the
lead singer for u2 plus you can spot his
3 u2 bandmates following behind him it's
a fun nod because at the time Queen in
u2's performances were considered by
many to be the best of the day and by
the way look early in the crowd shots as
is also a banner which reads we love you
too although this moment in the film
implies u2 played live aid right before
Queen in reality it was dire straits
here on stage before Freddie and Co
however just before we see that scene
again at the end of the film I think you
can hear dive straights music playing in
the background over various shots
including Freddie and it's baton mates
waiting in their trailer by the way if
you'd like to find out about some bigger
changes the movie made to Queens real
life story you can watch my other video
which I'll link to at the end and in the
video description
while original Queens bandmates Brian
May and Roger Taylor were involved in
Bohemian Rhapsody behind the scenes as
producers they didn't make an onscreen
cameo unless they were heavily disguised
as Mike Myers was however who did appear
was Queens new lead vocalist Adam
Lambert the former American Idol star
who's collaborated with Queen for over
six years made a cameo as a trucker
Lambert appears in the scene where
Freddy is on tour in the US and talking
on the phone to Mary who's back home in
England
Lambert Strucker then catches Freddie's
eye before going into the men's public
restroom now did you spot any other
interesting details or Queen Easter eggs
in Bohemian Rhapsody and what was your
favorite song in the movie let me know
in the comments below and remember to
subscribe for a chance to win one of
these cool Bohemian Rhapsody merch packs
tapleft to learn about the 7 scenes and
songs deleted from the movie or tap
write to learn
the biggest change is Bohemian Rhapsody
made to the real story of Queen let me
know if you enjoyed this and a thumbs up
and a share is always appreciated thanks
for watching and see you next time you'd
be going we'd be lovers